So it's Thursday, meaning we once again have
new unemployment numbers from last week.
The numbers are not good.
2.4 million more people filed for unemployment
benefits last week.
And this in total now it's starting to be
staggering.
Just unconscionable numbers when we total
up the job losses from these nine or so weeks
of corona virus unemployment, pandemic area
era.
Maybe it's 10 weeks at this point, something
like that.
We are now at thirty eight point six million
jobs lost.
If on February 1st, anybody had said.
My prediction is by June 1st, we will have
lost 40 million jobs, which is what it will
probably be after we add another week or two
of numbers.
I don't think anybody would have believed
it.
Now, if you want to find some kind of like
it could be worse type of thing in the numbers,
what we can point to is at least the numbers
are declining each week in terms of new people
losing their jobs in early April.
Each week we had like more than 6 million
people filed for new unemployment benefits.
And then by the end of April, early May, we
were at 4 million a week, 3 million a week.
And it sounds crazy, but that number is now
down to only 2.4 million more jobs lost last
week.
So in a sense, we're seeing a decreased rate
of people losing their jobs.
But once again, even with these diminishing
numbers, by mid-July, we could be at 50 million,
50 million people having lost their jobs.
Now, let's do a little bit of context, because
this is important when we talk about this.
The total workforce before the pandemic hit
was estimated at one hundred and fifty eight
million people.
So the country has three hundred and thirty
one million people.
Many of those are children.
Many of those are retired people.
So the active working labor force was believed
to be one hundred and fifty eight million
people.
So thirty eight point six million losing their
jobs means that twenty four point four.
Call it 25 percent.
About a quarter of the American workforce
lost jobs during the Corona virus pandemic.
Now, we've got to adjust those numbers a little
bit.
One way a little bit the other way.
One reality is these are probably underestimates
because there are lots of people who lost
jobs, but for one reason or another didn't
file unemployment benefits.
There may be people who lost a job, but they're
independently wealthy or have another source
of income or whatever.
And they just decided I'm not going to go
through the hassle of filing unemployment.
That's a small group of people.
You have a larger group of people who would
file an unemployment claim, except it's what
we might call a marginal job or a job that
is under the table, in which case you wouldn't
be able to file for unemployment benefits.
And there are still some fraction of people
who have just been struggling to get the claim
in because systems have been overloaded.
Unemployment is run at the state level, 50
states, 50 different systems.
Some are mostly phone, some are online combination
of the two.
So in a sense, these numbers are probably
too low now.
On the other side of this, there are people
who lost jobs early on but have found new
jobs.
So we have a cumulative total of thirty eight
point six million unemployment claims in the
last nine, 10, 11 weeks.
But some of those people who lost their job
in March, for example, have found a new job.
We don't know exactly what number that is,
but there are businesses that have been hiring
delivery, business based businesses, grocery
stores, places like Amazon and others have
been hiring.
So some of the people that lost jobs have
found new jobs.
Now, what we can be sure of is given this
bad news, the stock market is going to do
really, really well today.
And I'm sort of kidding.
But we've seen a stock market that's increasingly
divorced from the unemployment news.
Now, as we've talked about before, stock markets
often react to how the news compares to expectations.
So these new numbers of about two point forty
four million more people losing their jobs
last week.
It's more or less in line with expectations.
So it may not move the market very, very much.
So what we may actually see really shake up
the stock market would be the numbers that
we're going to get about the second quarter
in total.
So Q2 earnings and Q2 GDP may be numbers that
really move the stock market potentially down,
but maybe not.
So first you've got earnings seasons.
How much did companies make during the second
quarter?
And typically we get those numbers for the
second quarter, which is April, May, June,
around July 15th, we'll start to get earnings
numbers from companies.
And that may push the market up.
It may pull the market down.
Then we will get GDP numbers even later on.
So we'll get initial GDP estimates for the
second quarter on July 30th.
And then we'll get more accurate second quarter
GDP estimates towards the end of August, so
realize that we are not going to know the
full scope of what happened in this quarter
right now essentially until mid to late August,
almost September.
In practice, there are predictions that we
could see a 20 percent GDP decline in Q2 25
percent.
One estimate said 35 percent.
That's certainly on the very high end.
So this is about suffering.
It's not about politics.
But we can't ignore that.
Historically bad GDP numbers, the worst GDP
numbers the country has ever seen.
Eight weeks before a presidential election,
we will know the full scope of those those
numbers again, late August.
That may be very, very bad for Donald Trump.
Now, for now, as states have been improving
on their coronavirus numbers and putting in
place plans to get some portions of their
state economies back to work.
My hope is because, again, for me, this is
not political.
I want things to improve economically and
medically as quickly as is reasonably possible.
Some portions of people are going to be getting
back to work.
Hopefully things will tick up a bit or at
least at least continue ticking down less.
And reminder that the most important takeaway
here, we want to take what's going on and
turn it into action for the long term.
We've got to fix the problem now, of course,
over the long term.
The lesson here is even economies that look
really good by all of the traditional indicators
are really, really fragile.
Our lack of preparedness has been exposed
here.
There will be more pandemics.
There are going to be more downturns.
We can't control that.
What we can control is the underlying fragility
of our economic system.
And it's been exposed as very, very fragile.